[Musique]
on a fait des petits calculs et
aujourd'hui avec près de 60% des chevaux
de trait sur le sur le domaine on a
réduit de 2 15% nos émissions de notre
ville sur notre bilan carbone par
rapport aux autres acteurs et on fait
une économie à peu près de sa présente à
peu près 4 tonnes de co2
[Musique]
de plus en plus de domaines viticoles
souhaitent ou songent à réintroduire le
cheval dans la vigne parce que le cheval
s'avère une vraie alternative aux
énergies fossiles les chevaux vont par
exemple aller plus facilement sur des
terrains inaccessible aux tracteurs ils
vont moins de passer les sols et il ya
moins de sur une tenue ans sonore donc
c'est une alternative ou complémentaire
autres acteurs
[Musique]
sa justesse
donc en premier on leur apprend la
proche du cheval donc de là pour faire
connaissance avec les clés qui dira et
en produit en ce concerne la traction on
commence par la nash mans donc on leur
présente tout le harnais le ruc
l'utilité du harnais est donc là il en a
pris ça en début de semaine donc là
normalement elles sont complètement
autonome pour arracher leur cheval
le ventre
[Musique]